kids are hitting puberty about two years
earlier than they were a generation ago
yeah two to three actually the average
age for a girl to enter puberty in this
country is between 8 and 9 so that's a
lot earlier right I know thank you
because I would think it was 11 12 13 no
that's what it used to be so now it's
average 9 there's a broad spread right
there are always kids who are early to
it there are always kids who are late to
it but the average is much earlier third
fourth grade is very typical for the
first signs of puberty and is it the
same for boys yes but they are about a
year later so they're earlier too
between 9 and 10 but the girls beat them
so that cliche sometimes of girls mature
faster than boys it's not a cliche